UTTAM TRIPATHI:
Hello, and welcome
to this new, exciting
episode of GDL
that we're recording out
of the head of our studio
here in India.
And with me, I have our guest
for today, Amrit Sanjeev.
Amrit is the lead organizer of
Bangalore Android User Group.
He's also an Android
developer, and has
built some really
interesting apps that
are out there on the Play Store.
One of apps that he has one the
Play Store is called Paperboy.
And what Amrit plans to
talk to us today about
is his experience of using
some of the innovative ways
of getting customer feedback,
and making the app look
much nicer in terms of
the user experience,
and also fixing some
of the bugs and issues.
So before we get
started, Amrit, why
don't you quickly
introduce yourself
to the users in a
little bit more detail,
and talk about your app that
you have been working on,
and what are the things that
you used innovative channels.
AMRIT SANJEEV: Sure.
Sure.
The app that I was
actually working on
was a news reader application.
I was using the feed [INAUDIBLE]
back in to get the data.
And then we have
a very visual feed
to actually help the news as
actually conveyed to the user.
One of the things that I
wanted to work really hard on
was the user
experience of the app,
and I wanted to get a lot more
feedback on the application
from the general community.
For doing that, I
used three channels.
One is the in-app
feedback channel.
A second one is using
Google+ communities.
And the third one was using
the alpha/beta test channel.
UTTAM TRIPATHI: OK,
that's interesting, yeah.
So this in-app feedback
thing that you talked about,
so how did it really work?
Where were the users giving
the feedback, at what stage?
And how were you
collecting that feedback?
And then how did you use that
in your development cycle?
AMRIT SANJEEV: So from an
in-app feedback perspective,
the end in-app feedback
model is to allow the user
to give feedback from
within the app itself,
so that he's within the context.
The result is much
faster, and you
don't get premature negative
ratings for the app.
To measure the effectiveness
of it, what I did was initially
I gave a link for the user,
where the user could send me
an email with the feedback.
And from there, I
improved upon it
by opening the email application
within the app, where
they could send it again.
The third model was to have
it within the app itself.
And I saw that the
amount of feedback,
and the relevance
of the feedback
increased multifold
when I was using it
within the application.
UTTAM TRIPATHI: Well,
that's interesting.
Because you're
getting feedback right
from the user when he
or she is using the app,
I'm pretty sure their feedback
would be much more relevant.
So I think that
makes a lot of sense.
What about the other things
that you talked about,
Google+ communities and
alpha/beta channels?
How did you use them?
AMRIT SANJEEV: To kind of
improve the user experience
of the app, what I actually
did was I first identified
the relevant communities
within Google+.
Then I gave them my application,
the link to my application,
and also the ideas that I'm
really looking forward to.
And for me, the two channels
that really worked really well
was Android Apps, and also
the Android Design community.
Both of these communities
gave great feedback,
and some of them
helped me quite a lot
in terms of refining the app,
getting those finer details
right, and also telling me
the perspectives and the rules
behind how they engineer stuff.
As an engineer, from a
technical perspective,
I was kind of OK doing things.
But from a design
perspective, there
are new things that I
learned from the community.
And people were very open
and willing to teach you.
And that was the
best part of it all.
UTTAM TRIPATHI: Perfect, yeah.
And alpha/beta channels?
AMRIT SANJEEV: So the
alpha/beta channel, I
saw a lot of benefit using that.
So the way I had
actually structured,
was that the alpha channel
was useful within the app.
So the nightly bills used to
go within the app development
team.
And the beta channel was used
for a demography of users
that I had actually chosen
based on different age
groups, different
devices that they had,
their reading patterns,
and things like that,
so that I had a very
varied set of users
within the beta community.
So we released the stable
version to the beta community,
they would actually test the
app and give you feedback
on it, things for you to improve
before you hit the main market,
where it is open for everybody.
So when the beta
test channel is kind
of giving the approval for what
you have, then you actually
pushed it to the main
community, the amount
of feedback that you were
getting in terms of changes
was much less.
UTTAM TRIPATHI: That
makes a lot of sense.
So using all these three things
that you had described right
now, what kind of impact
did it have on your app?
Did it improve the
ratings that you
were getting from the users?
Did it impact the downloads?
What kind of impact did you see?
AMRIT SANJEEV: I saw an increase
in downloads, definitely.
The user experience of the app
was increased dramatically,
because people were actually
giving me that feedback.
The third thing which I found,
which is most interesting,
was that my app
rating did increase.
And in that, the most impactful,
or the most interesting thing,
has been the fact that people
who were actually giving me
three stars, and then
went ahead and changed it
because I was
getting that feedback
and I was communicating
back to them.
And every time there was a
change, or an improvement,
or the feature they
requested has come in,
I was able to communicate it
back directly into their app.
So when they were
opening the app,
they got the message that your
feature has been implemented.
And that made people
very happy, happy enough
that they came back
to the Play Store
and changed the rating
to a higher one.
UTTAM TRIPATHI: I would
like to do that same thing.
If I give a feedback
to a developer,
and he or she goes
back and implements it,
it makes sense to go back
and give a higher rating
because they implemented
what you had requested.
So perfect.
Thanks.
I think this is
really interesting.
So for our viewers,
if someone wants
to use some of the methods
that you just described,
what would be the
starting point?
How can they get started?
Is there documentation
available online
that they can just go to?
What would be your
suggestion for that?
AMRIT SANJEEV: For
the in-app feedback,
there are actually
libraries by which
you can very quickly test.
I tested two libraries,
Apptentive and also HockeyApp.
They were the ones
that I've actually
tested and saw
their differences.
So they're very
easy to integrate.
They've been
[INAUDIBLE] in a way
that you write
minimal amount of code
to integrate them
within the app.
And for alpha/beta test
channel, developer.android.com
has all the details for it.
And the [INAUDIBLE]
also gives you
the interface to do
that very easily.
There is not much of a
difficulty doing that,
and you can manage your
application very easily
at that point.
UTTAM TRIPATHI:
Perfect, yeah, I think
that makes a lot of sense.
So thanks a lot
once again, Amrit.
It was a pleasure having
you on our show today.
And we look forward
to having you
for more shows in the future.
So thanks a lot for
sharing your insights,
and all of best with your
development projects.
AMRIT SANJEEV: Thanks.
Thanks for the opportunity.
UTTAM TRIPATHI: Thanks viewers.
So with this, we'll
sign off from the show.
But do keep watching
GDL shows as we continue
to share some of the
insights from developers
across the world.
Thanks once again.
See you.